es gibt unrecht das liegt so schwer dass
es unverzeihlich scheint dazu gehört wo
das was in der schweiz unter dem titel
der administrativen versorgung tausenden
von menschen bis 1981 angetan worden ist
wer als arbeitsscheu oder liederlich
gold konnte ohne gerichtsurteil oder
psychiatrisches gutachten weggesperrt
werden
der spielfilm linie an den diesjährigen
festspielen in solothurn den
publikumspreis gewonnen hat erzählt von
einem solchen schicksal
die 17 jährige lina stammt aus der
unterschicht und verliebt sich ende der
60er jahre in den sohn eines großbürgers
die liebesbeziehung ist den herrschaften
im dorf ein dorn im auge li na wird so
nach erziehung in ein heim gesteckt und
nach ihrer flucht ins gefängnis
hindelbank gesperrt dort gewährte ein
kind das sie zur adoption freigeben muss
heute abend feiert der film li na auf
sf1 seine fernsehpremiere anlass wir uns
in der sternstunde philosophie darüber
nachzudenken ob und wie solch schweres
unrecht wiedergutgemacht werden kann wie
wir überhaupt mit schuld im leben
umgehen und was wir eigentlich tun wenn
wir verzeihen kann im studio ist jetzt
svenja flaßpöhler sie ist
stellvertretende chefredakteurin des
philosophie magazins und sie hat ein
buch geschrieben über das verzeihen und
dem umgang mit schuld herzlich
willkommen wenn ihr fast müller vielen
dank dafür dass sie haben sich im
vorfeld zu unserem gespräch dem film
lina bereits angesehen was hat sie am
meisten berührt mich hat der ganze film
sehr berührt am meisten aber wohl die
szene der geburt als lina ihren sohn
bekommt im gefängnis der sohn wird
eigentlich direkt nach der geburt schon
weggenommen weil er eben zur adoption
freigegeben werden soll liegt dann wird
ihr dann aber noch mal für einige
sekunden gnädigerweise auf den bauch
gelegt und diese diese ähnlichkeit ist
sehr berührend und dann aber vor allem
der moment als der sohn dann endgültig
also aus dem raum getragen wird und lina
im
anschluss ihren kopf gegen die wand
knallt gegen die tür knallt aus lauter
schmerz das hat mich glaube ich wirklich
am meisten berührt und mir regelrecht
die kehle zugeschnürt vielleicht auch
damit zu tun haben dass sie selber erst
vor kurzem zum zweiten mal mutter
geworden sie sicherlich wer also diesen
zu diesem moment der ähnlichkeit denn
kennt glaube ich jede mutter was was man
spürt wenn dieses kind auf der brust
liegt und man sich einfach
unbeschreiblich freut und und überhaupt
die tatsache dass das kind eben aus dem
körper heraus gekommen ist und man es
auch festhalten will und nicht mehr
hergeben möchte und ich glaube dieses
gefühl dass man das kind nicht mehr in
sich trägt aber auch nicht bei sich hat
das ist das ist das muss so schmerzhaft
sein also ich kann es nur an
schauen wir uns doch gemeinsam einen
ausschnitt aus lina an ich habe einen
ausschnitt aus gewählt in dem lena
bereits in diesen gefängnissen
hindelbank ist sie kriegt zum ersten mal
die möglichkeit einen brief zu schreiben
sie schreibt ihn haben julian ihren
geliebten und die aufseherin nimmt den
brief weg liest ihn und zitiert dann li
na beim direktor sie muss davor sprechen
weil der brief sozusagen in ungnade
fällt schauen wir uns diese szene an
[Musik]
das ist der erste brief schreiben darf
ich denke jeden tag an dich
jede stunde jede minute
ich denke dann wo wir jetzt sein könnten
du dich
[Musik]
es gibt keine fragen hier nehmen und
lacht und ich darf dich nicht lebendig
begraben julian ich weiß nicht wie ich
das aushalten können ein jahr lang
vielleicht sogar zwei jahre
sie haben es mir nicht genau gesagt
das schlimmste sind die würmer im haus
das löste sich nicht einmal die
mörderinnen es gibt sogar wirklich nette
darunter
das schlimmste sind die black hätte wir
von den wärterinnen bekommen als ob wir
nichts werden oder noch weniger als
nichts
gerade gut genug um dieses land regiert
wird ungleich behandelt lebendig
begraben
was von einer massiv lolland russell der
sicherste möglichkeit zum getäuscht
hätten das wünscht sie kleider ihr nicht
wahr ist dass ihr werdet ihr sicher
zuordnen oder wenigstens könntet ihr das
leere wenn da nicht sondern denkt und
undankbar werdet es wenn man den brief
und vorläufig ist radio danke frau
hamann
platz für das sie befassten sich in
ihrem buch verzeihen vom umgang mit
schuld mit schuld mit moralischem
unglück mit bösen wie kann man so
grausam sein
ich denke man kann da zwei momente
unterscheiden also zum einen ist da
natürlich einfach der blinden gehorsam
gegenüber regeln die geltenden sitten
die gelten und es ist ja eine form von
gedankenlosigkeit natürlich auch dabei
diesen regeln einfach so ohne sie
hinterfragen zu befolgen und damit
menschen einfach zutiefst zu kränken
das andere ist aber sicherlich auch dass
lina in ihrer in ihrer unglaublichen
lebendigkeit das sieht man jetzt hier in
dieser szene nicht aber ansonsten im
film es ist eine unglaublich lebendige
liebes fähige frau und diese wärterin
das hat man ja auch ganz gut gesehen und
auch der herr der dame schreibtisch
sitzt den fehlt jede lebendigkeit und
wahrscheinlich auch jede liebesfähigkeit
und insofern sind natürlich so frauen
wie lena immer auch eine gefahr für
diese menschen weil sie ihm ihre eigenen
ja ihre eigene mangelhaftigkeit immer
auch vorführen und diese regeln die da
also so blind befolgt werden ermöglichen
es ja wort wörtlich die gefahr
wegzusperren und das glaube ich ist ein
ganz entscheidender motivationsgrund für
diese leute ein stück weit wurden diese
maßnahmen jahr griffen mit der idee
diese menschen auf den rechten weg
zurückzubringen
das heißt man hat ja eine idee des guten
und wollte den menschen eine neue chance
geben
glauben sie in solchen systemen dass die
der einzelnen personen die das dann
durchziehen wirklich daran glauben etwas
gutes zu tun
das kann ich das kann ich nicht sagen
man kann sich natürlich nicht wirklich
in diese menschen hineinversetzen aber
es ist natürlich schon die frage ob man
mit ein bisschen nachdenken nicht auf
die idee kommen kann dass dieser rechte
weg von dem dann immer die rede ist
alles andere als der rechte weg ist ich
meine es wird ja einfach versucht den
den menschen oder in diesem fall den
frauen männer waren ja wohl auch
betroffen
wirklich das denken ab zu erziehen also
sie zu wirklich auch genauso zu blind zu
brechen sie zu brechen sie genauso zu
blindem gehorsam zu erziehen eben ihnen
eben wirklich auch jede lebendigkeit
auszutreiben und ich meine es ist eine
zeit da lag der faschismus noch nicht so
weit zurück also das kam mir jetzt
gerade auch als deutscher noch mal so in
den
das da im grunde eine logik fortgeführt
wird die wir schon mal hatten und sie
die zu einer katastrophe geführt hat
insofern denke ich man muss den menschen
zutrauen dass sie die fähigkeit haben
bestimmte regeln zu hinterfragen das hat
ja hannah arendt im übrigen sehr schön
auch gezeigt mit ihrem begriff des
banalen bösen mit diesem begriff
beschreibt sie ja das was der so
genannte schreibtischtäters adolf
eichmann getan hat nämlich millionen
juden gedankenlos in den tod getrieben
und eichmann hat sich ja immer wieder
damit entschuldigt hat gesagt ich habe
einfach nur regeln befolgt ich habe das
getan was von mir erwartet wurde
und da sagt sie das ist die banalität
des bösen diese gedankenlosigkeit diese
unfähigkeit das system zu hinterfragen
über den gesprächen doch dagegen
anzukämpfen
ihr buch verzeihen vom umgang mit schuld
das erscheint am 8 märz im buchhandel
ist also ganz druckfrisch sozusagen das
setzt ja an bei ihrer eigenen geschichte
sie gehen sozusagen von ihrer eigenen
biografie auch sie wurden als sie 14
waren von ihrer eigenen mutter verlassen
ja erzählen sie richtig also ich habe zu
dem zeitpunkt mit meinen geschwistern
schon mit meinem stiefvater und meiner
mutter zusammen gelebt also es gab schon
mal eine trennung meiner mutter hatte
sich schon von meinem vater getrennt als
ich sehr sehr klein war und als ich 14
war verließ uns meine unsere mutter für
einen weiteren mann ihrem dritten
ehemann und ich habe eben noch sehr
genau diesen moment in erinnerung in dem
sie dann tatsächlich geht also diese
sprachlosigkeit auch von seiten meiner
mutter weil es ja überhaupt keinen kein
keines kann skript gibt für diese für
diese szene was sagt man wenn eine
mutter ihre kinder verlässt und diese
sprachlosigkeit die hat mich sehr sehr
lange auch beschäftigt und hat mich
glaube ich auch jetzt dazu gebracht für
mich worte dafür zu finden was da
eigentlich genau passiert ist und
nachdem sie dann also weg war das war so
gar nicht jetzt so das schlimmste dass
sie gingen sondern das was mindestens
genauso schlimm war weil der
kontaktabbruch also sie hat dann
tatsächlich um dieses neue leben zu
beginn den kontakt zu uns weitgehend
abgebrochen
auch ganz wir hatten dann jahrelang
überhaupt keine ja keine kommunikation
kein kein gespräch keine zusammenkunft
mehr
und das hat mich schon sehr sehr lange
sehr sehr tief beschäftigt haben sie
ihre mutter vermisst
naja nicht wirklich offensichtlich also
ich hab natürlich mich irgendwie damit
auch abgefunden das ist ja auch
interessant das werden wahrscheinlich
viele nachvollziehen können man findet
sich ja auch ab mit dem was passiert man
empfindet das auch ein stück weit als
normal
es ist ja auch gar nicht so dass man
dass man ständig irgendwie in den
schmerz an das zurück denkt sondern das
problem ist ja fast er dass dieser
schmerz ja auch verkapselt ist ja also
dass der irgendwie ganz tief im inneren
sitzt und man ihn gar nicht so richtig
spürt man auch irgendwann sich so an
trainiert darüber zu reden als sei das
irgend etwas ganz normales man redet
darüber wie man umzug macht so passiert
halt irgendwann und man zieht dann in
eine andere stadt ja und meine mutter
hat mich irgendwann verlassen oder uns
und ich habe dann aber irgendwann eben
gemerkt dass dieser verkapselten schmerz
der ja eben bestimmte symptome dann
trotzdem hervor treibt ja und an diesen
symptomen leidet man dann eher dass
diese symptome irgendwann so nach und
nach verschwanden und ich mich irgendwie
innerlich so wie befreit gefühlt habe
davon von dieser geschichte und diese
befreiung also dieses dieses auflösung
der symptome das hat mich dann
eigentlich dazu gebracht mich irgendwann
zu fragen bin ich vielleicht dabei zu
verzeihen und dieser begriff der ist ja
sehr geheimnisvoll oder mich hat er
zumindest irgendwie ins nachdenken
gebracht weil ich mich dann gefragt habe
was heißt das eigentlich genau
er hat mir noch ganz kurz mit dem
begriff des land seien sie sind
vielleicht auch festhalten wir sprechen
hier jetzt über ein unrecht das ihnen
angetan worden ist ich wenn man kann ja
solche dinge eigentlich überhaupt nicht
vergleichen und trotzdem wage ich den
vergleich
das liegt vielleicht weniger schwer sie
wurden jetzt nicht körperlich geschlagen
oder im gefängnis eingesperrt und
trotzdem sind es vielleicht parallele
welt sind insofern aus einem etwas
widerfährt was man ganz ganz schwer
verdauen kann und sie machen sich aus in
ihrem buch auf die suche nach diesem
phänomen des vereins
in einem ersten schritt versuchen sie
erst mal zu verstehen was bringt einem
das verstehen in solchen kontext nach
dem möchte man verstehen die das
verstehen ermöglicht es das was da
passiert ist ein stück weit von sich weg
zu rücken
man kriegt eine distanz zu dem was was
geschehen ist und man kommt in die in
die lage sich tatsächlich zu fragen
warum ist das eigentlich passiert
inwiefern hatte das möglicherweise jetzt
gar nicht etwas mit mir als person zu
tun sondern hat was mit mit der person
mit dem täter der täter wenn er
irgendwie nicht haben das kommt er zum
beispiel dann kann man sich sagen ich
muss es nicht persönlich nie richtig
habe einfach krank richtig genau also
das ist natürlich ich sag jetzt mal so
der idealfall man kommt irgendwann zu
der erkenntnis diese person konnte gar
nicht anders handeln das haben wir ja
genau in dem film li na also der sohn
erfährt ja nach und nach diese
geschichte seiner mutter und erkennt
irgendwann dass sagt er dann ja auch
ganz am ende du hattest keine schuld und
in diesem moment also man wirklich sagt
diese person konnte überhaupt nicht
anders handeln
dann erübrigt sich aber im übrigen auch
das verzeihen ja wo gleich ganz kurz
erklären also das ist im grunde genommen
der sohn der in diesem gefängnis geboren
wird gern er bietet sozusagen bild die
rahmenhandlung von lina er sucht nämlich
seine mutter die linie auf seine
leibliche mutter und dann kommt diese
ganze geschichte wird einen dann erzählt
und er erkennt sozusagen er wurde nicht
auf bösen motiven recht geben können
sondern sie konnte nicht wie konnte
nicht anders und er entschuldigt sie ja
er sagt wirklich du hattest keine schuld
das ist natürlich der idealfall der der
dann eintritt wenn man versteht wenn man
versucht die die position des anderen
nachzuvollziehen
in meinem fall und wahrscheinlich in
sehr vielen fällen ist es aber so dass
man erkennt gerade durch das verstehen
dass es auch eine grenze gibt also dass
man irgendwann an den punkt kommt
festzustellen es gab aber ein rest
freiheit die diese person gehabt hätte
sie musste nicht so handeln sie ist
nicht determiniert gewesen durch regeln
durch sonst irgendetwas sondern es gab
diesen moment der freiheit und da muss
ich sagen also wir sind tatsächlich
einige parallelen auch aufgefallen
zwischen dieser figur li na
und meiner mutter ja also auch meine
mutter war bestimmten repressalien
ausgesetzt also das ist ja eine ähnliche
generation
meine mutter ist auch in einem sehr sehr
restriktiven umfeld groß geworden wo
frauen irgendwie ja auch nicht begehren
durften sich nicht frei entwickeln
durften ja sehr sehr strenge eltern sehr
sehr strengen vater meine mutter hat
sich im übrigen auch in einen revoluzzer
verliebt er dann mein vater wurde also
ich hab da so ein paar parallelen
erkannt nachdem sie sich in ihn verliebt
hatte und mit mit mir schwanger war
haben ihre eltern den kontakt
abgebrochen
aber und hier endet jetzt die parallele
meine mutter ist nie in ein heim
gekommen meine mutter ist nie ins
gefängnis gekommen meine mutter wurde
nicht dazu gezwungen mich weg zu geben
es gab sozusagen im späteren leben
möglichkeiten sich so oder so zu
entscheiden und genau da an dieser
grenze wird das verzeihen virulent ja in
dem moment wo man sagen muss diese
person ist tatsächlich in einer
bestimmten weise vielleicht gezwungen
gewesen oder einem druck ausgesetzt
gewesen
aber es bleibt es bleibt eine schuld es
bleibt eine schuld und mit dieser schuld
umzugehen das ist doch eigentlich die
herausforderung
sie besuchen in ihrem buch ja auch
unterschiedliche personen die mit ganz
großen unrecht oder mit bösen
konfrontiert worden sind und dann
sprechen sie mit der mutter eines opfers
des amoklaufes in winnenden 1991 nein
das ist falsch 2009 entschuldigung 2009
hatte ein 17 jähriger schüler in einer
realschule in winnenden 15 schüler
erschossen und auch lehrpersonen und
eines dieser opfer war die nina meyer
und deren mutter besuchen sieben und
diese mutter erzählt ihnen dann dass sie
genau das versucht hatte hat versucht
den mörder zu entschuldigen insofern
dass sie sich gesagt hat er
wahrscheinlich einfach krank und
trotzdem bleibt sie stehen auch bei
diesem moment was erkennen muss das
stimmt nicht wirklich der hätte anders
handeln können
genau das heißt wirklich verstehen kann
sich ja dann schlussendlich nicht nein
aber sie kann auch nicht anders als
verstehen zu wollen ich glaube das muss
man eben auch sagen dass dieses
verstehen wollen glaube ich ein zutiefst
menschliches begehren auch ist
in dem moment wo ich wo ich nicht
verstehe wo ich einfach nur opfer bin wo
ich sozusagen nur sehe was da mir
angetan wurde oder in diesem falle der
tochter und indirekt natürlich auch ihr
weil sie hat ihre tochter verloren bin
ich komplett passiv ich kann sozusagen
nur erleiden
gleichzeitig ist diese tat irgendwie
auch in mir drin ich habe überhaupt
keine möglichkeit sie sie irgendwie auf
distanz zu rücken und diese frau diese
mutter die übrigens sehr sehr klar war
auch philosophin ist die die die conti
sagt ich konnte gar nicht anders sie
musste versuchen irgendwann am anfang
war sie natürlich sprachlos und einfach
nur wütend und und konnte überhaupt
nichts tun also es war nennt nimmt die
depression auch die sie hatte aber
irgendwann begangen das so erzählt sie
das ist begann und sie konnte gar nicht
anders als zu versuchen sich mit dieser
geschichte des täters
auseinanderzusetzen und sie sagt das hat
sie schon sie beschreibt es so wie man
geht wandern und man kommt irgendwann
über die baumgrenze und mann gehalten
man hat irgendwie auf einen blick man
kann sich umsehen man man hat überblick
und diese befreiung die hat sich schon
gespürt und dieses hat dieses verstehen
ist eben bei ihr einhergegangen mit
einem verzeihens prozess von dem sie
aber sagt er ist und abschließbar
genauso wie das verstehen und
abschließbar ist weil das erzählt sie
sehr eindrücklich sie sagt dieser dieser
junge der war ja nicht außer sich ja der
war ja nicht irgendwie besessen sondern
der ist ganz das haben dann zeugen
später erzählte es ganz entspannt über
den gang geschlendert und hat diese
kinder erschossen und die referendarin
nina mayer die ihre tochter war und in
dem moment das aktie dann auch klar der
hat das verstehen auf und trotzdem
weigert sie sich den begriff des bösen
zu verwenden weil das ein dämonisieren
der begriff ist den sie auf diesen täter
nicht anwenden würde
sie haben ihr buch ihrer mutter gewidmet
weiß ihre mutter von diesem buch jetzt
hatte ich gelesen ja sie hat es gelesen
und das war natürlich auch die ganze
zeit beim schreiben mir klar dass ich
meiner mutter dieses buch auch bevor es
dann in die welt kommt auch zeigen würde
also ich hab ja wieder kontakt zu meiner
mutter seit einigen jahren
und sehe sie nicht oft aber aber
regelmäßig und mir wäre es falsch
vorgekommen dieses buch einfach in die
welt zu setzen ohne dass vorher einmal
zu zeigen gleichwohl war ich mir auch
sicher dass ich mich beim schreiben
nicht zensieren lassen will und dass ich
auch nicht wenn sie jetzt das buch nicht
mitgetragen hätte mich davon ich hätte
abbringen lassen
aber sie hat es mit gesicht trägt es mit
also sie hat es gelesen und trägt es ich
habe mich dabei ertappt beim lesen dass
ich dazwischen dachte unglaublich was
ihnen widerfahren ist und mit dieser
frau muss man überhaupt kein mitleid
haben und gleichzeitig darf nicht auf
man das so viel privates ausplaudern mit
dem ihre mutter jetzt auch konfrontiert
ist oder trägt einen anderen namen wie
sie sie trägt einen anderen nachnamen
als ich und ich habe mich natürlich beim
schreiben schon sehr bemüht die ja diese
die gratwanderung hinzubekommen also
schon zu erzählen man muss glaube ich
erzählen auch wenn man über dieses thema
schreibt muss man erzählen weil weil das
verzeihen ist ja nichts was ich rein
theoretisch jetzt aus der distanz ab
handeln ließ sondern ich glaube dass man
um das verzeihen zu verstehen auch
geschichten erzählen muss erzählen muss
und sich geschichten auch anhören muss
also man kann da von einer form des
narrativen philosophie entsprechen weil
viel viel wird einem auch klar wenn man
erzählt wenn man versucht die worte zu
finden wenn man versucht auch seine
eigene geschichte eben in worte zu
fassen diese sprachlosigkeit zu
überwinden
da wird einem viel darüber das verzeihen
klar und insofern war mir auch klar ich
kann dieses buch nicht schreiben und
vielleicht nur mit einem satz andeuten
dass ich auch irgendwie betroffen bin
sondern ich muss das schon ich muss das
schon auch nach außen tragen also die
erinnerung nach außen tragen und
gleichzeitig mich aber auch nicht
expedition ihren ja oder meine mutter
jetzt sozusagen ausstellen wie so ein
objekt her und ich hoffe dass mir diese
gratwanderung gelungen ist und hat die
mutter sich geäußert zum buch ja also
sie sie trägt es mit sie
sie findet es gelungen sie ist natürlich
auch immer wieder über stellen auch
gestolpert war auch sehr wie soll ich
sagen berührt oder betroffen und ihr
sind glaube ich auch beim lesen auch
möglicherweise noch mal dinge klar
geworden weil ja dieses ganze thema auch
etwas ist worüber wir so nie wirklich
direkt gesprochen haben also auch als
ich dann irgendwann wieder kontakt zu
meiner mutter aufgenommen habe weil ich
eben im gemerkt habe irgendwas feld von
mir ab irgendwas ermöglicht mir auch
wieder diesen kontakt aufzunehmen war
jetzt auch gar nicht meine intention ich
muss jetzt meine mutter noch mal zur
rede stellen ich will da jetzt eine
entschuldigung oder ich will heute das
dass das war für mich überhaupt nicht
wichtig die höhe meiner mutter ist mir
überhaupt nicht wichtig das kann ich
wirklich über das ganz überzeugt so
sagen ich brauche nicht jetzt diese
geste der entschuldigung von ihrer seite
sondern wichtig war mir kontakt mit ihr
zu haben weil es meine mutter ist
tatsächlich und weil weil ich mein leben
ohne sie gar nicht denken kann ich bin
mit ihr verbunden es ist meine mutter
und insofern ja es ist einfach eine form
von notwendigkeit für mich gewesen eine
innere notwendigkeit die aber ganz
unabhängig davon ist wie sich jetzt
meine mutter zu dieser geschichte stellt
und dann aber durch die lektüre dieses
buch ist habe ich schon gemerkt dass sie
das berührt und das hat mich natürlich
das kann ich ja auch gar nicht für ihn
natürlich hat mich das gefreut
es ist ja so dass viele menschen die ein
großes unrecht widerfährt auch berichten
dass sie sich dafür schämen und
eigentlich ist das erstmal ja eigentlich
ganz verkehrt man schämt sich für etwas
wofür man überhaupt nichts kann und
eigentlich sollten sich die täter oder
täterin entscheiden
haben sie sich je geschämt ich glaube
nie so richtig bewusst geschämt aber was
man auf jeden fall oder was ich in jedem
fall sagen kann ist ja dass eine tat die
einem widerfährt die einem angetan wurde
eine art makel oder mangel einpflanzt ja
so man wird ja durch diese tat
gedemütigt oder man wird eher niedrig
tja was ich eine person die vergewaltigt
wird man also das ist jetzt wirklich ein
krasses sehr eindrückliches beispiel
genau eine person die vergewaltigt die
missbraucht wird die wird durch diese
tat gedemütigt und erniedrigt entwertet
und diese entwertung die trägt das opfer
in sich als makel als mangel und das ist
der grund der scham
das ist natürlich ungerecht aber es ist
so dass passiert und es geht ja sogar so
weit dass die opfer sich nicht nur
schämen sondern sich ja sogar auch mit
schuldig fühlen ja in dem sinne
ich bin selber daran schuld dass es mir
das und das widerfahren ist und das sind
natürlich mechanismen die die diät
selbstzerstörerisch sind zerstörerisch
sind und die man denke ich nur mit ganz
viel arbeit aufbringen kann um nicht
allen gelingt das jahr man weiß dass es
opfer gibt es holocaust zb um ein
extrembeispiel zu nehmen die sich
schlussendlich das leben genommen haben
deren die an primo levi denken die an
jean améry menschen die zerbrochen sind
die einfach nicht mehr damit fertig
geworden sind und in diesem kontext kann
mir das konzept der resilienz in den
sinn
ein konzept das der französische
psychoanalytiker boris sie wenig
entwickelt haben es der selber jahr sein
opfer seien eltern waren opfer des
holocaust er selber hat ganz ganz
furchtbare sachen erlebt und hat dieses
konzept der resilienz entwickelt und
gesagt es ist interessant dass es
menschen gibt die aus dem
allerschlimmsten ihrem leben die
unglaublichsten erfolgen auch er
zusammenzimmern
wie kommt es dazu warum gelingt das den
ein und den anderen nicht ja das ist das
große geheimnis das er übrigens schon
mit schirm trieben hat der hat ja von
ihm stammt ja dieser satz was mich nicht
umbringt macht mich stärker und er
spricht von einer plastizität von einer
kraft der plastizität der ist gelingt in
manchen menschen wunden auszuheilen wie
als wie ich habe mir das so vorgestellt
wie eine eine pflanze der irgendwie ein
stengel abgehackt wird und diese pflanze
treibt aus sich selbst heraus einen
neuen möglicherweise noch die schöneren
stengel hervor oder blüte oder was auch
immer das gelingt residenten personen
also resilienz meint ja erstmal dem wort
nach abprallen
das finde ich aber gar nicht so treffend
also dieses abbrand das klingt so
nachrüstung als würde man da irgendwas
außen halten sondern ich glaube was
residente persönlichkeiten ja eher
ausmacht ist dass sie aus der ich sag
jetzt mal so aus der wunde etwas machen
aus dass aus dieser wunde erwächst etwas
sie können den eigenen den eigenen
schmerz war
in etwas positives und warum dass manche
personen haben und andere nicht ich
glaube dass es letzten endes immer noch
nicht so ganz geklärt und gleichzeitig
und ich denke das zeigt dass könig ja
auch in seinen büchern muss man wissen
muss man dieser dieser figur der
resilienz unter diesem begriff der
resilienz auch mit etwas vorsicht
begegnen weil er natürlich nicht sagt
residente persönlichkeiten die haben das
jetzt ein für alle mal überwunden
die sind sozusagen unangreifbar sondern
was er eben auch betont und das würde
ich zum beispiel von mir auch sagen dass
residente person gerade durch diesen
mangel durch diesen gestörten mangel zum
beispiel sehr sehr ehrgeizig sind ja sie
wollen diesen mangel irgendwie durch
besondere leistungsfähigkeit wettmachen
und sind sozusagen das auch dazu
gezwungen in gewisser weise beruflich
erfolgreich zu sein auch in ihrem leben
glücklich zu sein wie um sich zu
beweisen ich habe das jetzt ich hab' das
überwunden ich habe das verwunden und
insofern ist das konzept vielleicht auch
fast ein bisschen gefährlich wenn man
den eindruck kann sie den einen die eben
zerbrechen wird dann fast schon implizit
vorgeworfen guck mal die anderen machen
dann aus erst recht richtig stärken
richtig in der folge richtig gesagt es
ist ein sehr es ist ein ambivalentes
konzept natürlich gerade auch in zeiten
der der der leistungsgesellschaft ja
dass man sagen kann das ist auch eine
affirmative begriffen unkritischer dem
system gegenüber unkritischer begriff
der ja im grunde genommen sagt streng
dich mal ein bisschen an und dann kannst
du doch sogar was daraus machen
also anstatt einfach auch zu sagen leid
ist leid und das hat auch das recht leid
sein zu dürfen ja also oder auch ein
recht auf unproduktivität zu haben eine
gewisse zeit im leben und auch trauern
zu dürfen zum beispiel
insofern ja das ist ein das ist ein sehr
ambivalente begriff und ich habe jetzt
jüngst ein buch gelesen was mich auch
sehr bewegt hat das kommt jetzt
demnächst auch heraus von dem benedict
wells das heißt das ende der einsamkeit
und wo er eben auch von einer sehr
schmerzhaften kindheitserfahrungen
erzählt und da fällt dieser wunderbaren
satz ich weiß nicht ob ich ihn jetzt
wörtlich hinbekomme aber da sagt er die
die kindheit oder eine schwere kind
es ist ein unsichtbarer feind der
jederzeit wieder zuschlagen kann
und das fand ich beunruhigend und
gleichzeitig auch treffend weil
natürlich niemand auch jetzt menschen
die eigentlich denke ich habe das ganz
gut verarbeitet und ich habe ein leben
was mich sehr glücklich macht nie so
richtig ganz sicher wissen können ob
nicht da möglicherweise doch noch der
schmerz irgendwo sitzt und sich eines
tages wieder zeigt sprechen wir über das
verzeichnen sozusagen das thema was sie
eben umkreisen
sie stellen das wird ein stück weit
sogar was sie sagen das ist so was wie
ein moralischer schuldenschnitt wir
gehen hin und sagen lass gut sein
eigentlich schließt du mir etwas weil du
hast mir eine runter gehauen oder sehr
viel schlimmeres getan aber schwamm
drüber
wir lassen es mal gut sein eigentlich
relativ die rational warum tut man so
was man verzeihen was sie sagen das ist
erst mal finde ich fand ich jetzt beim
schreiben dieses buches auch interessant
dass er dieser begriff des verzeihens
tatsächlich den verzicht in sich trägt
also verzeihen bedeutet verzicht auf
vergeltung während ja der begriff des
vergebens den es ja auch gibt die gabe
betont also dann man gibt etwas man gibt
etwas dem anderen das verzeihen und das
ist ja der weltliche begriff deshalb hat
er mich eigentlich mehr interessiert ist
wirklich diese verzicht leistung ich
verzichte auf die rache und gleichzeitig
und das sprechen sie ja an daran zeigt
sich auch letztlich die irrationalität
an diese handlung weil natürlich das
verzeihen das ist nicht logisch das ist
auch nicht ökonomisch das ist noch nicht
mal gerecht das verzeihen ist wirklich
ein es auch etwas was sich ereignet das
ist ja nichts wo man sagen kann jetzt
verzeichne mal und dann geht es dir
wieder besser das hat nichts normatives
ich kann ich jemandem sagen jetzt hat
zwei mal genauso wie jemandem sagen kann
jetzt liebt doch mal sondern das ist
etwas was natürlich bestimmte
bedingungen braucht um sich ereignen zu
können aber es bleibt immer auch ein
stück weit und verfügbar ist geschieht
auf ein gelingen es ist ja es muss
glücken würde ich sagen und das ist eben
dieses glück also es bleibt ein moment
des un- verfügbaren darin und es ist
eben wirklich auch nichts wo man sagen
kann davon habe ich jetzt unmittelbar
irgendetwas
es ist eben auch ein ein geschenk an den
anderen ein geschenk ist so wieder sowie
der ökonomische schuldenschnitt auch er
zu sagen du wirst diese schuld nie
begleichen können sie wird nie zu
begleichen sein und gerade deshalb
machen wir diesen schuldenschnitt um uns
beide von dieser vergangenheit und von
dieser tat zu lösen dich zu lösen mich
zu lösen beide zu lösen weil das habe
ich mich gefragt für wenigstens parteien
eigentlich wichtiger und besser will den
personen die das unrecht begangen hat
oder für das opfer
tja also ich würde sagen es ist
natürlich für beide wichtig gleichzeitig
muss man finde ich aber auch vorsichtig
sein weil ich denke nicht dass dass man
sagen kann oder ich sage es mal anders
das verzeihen ist letztlich also dieser
verzicht ist ja eine form der gabe wenn
sie mir jetzt etwas antun und ich sage
ich verzichte auf vergeltung dann
schenke ich ihnen auch etwas und dieses
geschenk da ist eben die frage ist das
jetzt wirklich sozusagen ganz
intentional tue ich das um mich selber
zu heilen oder geschieht es eben auch
ein stück weit selbst los oder
bedingungslos her und das sei ja auch
wieder gut tun kann das waren ja sicher
schon leute spenden und fühlen sich gut
dabei und sicher auch ein schöner
nebeneffekt sicher und ich will auch gar
nicht verhehlen dass es dass es
natürlich um verzeihen zu können
bestimmter bedingungen bedarf und das
ist natürlich das habe ich ja wohl noch
versucht zu zeigen oder zu sagen also
das einher geht auch mit einer befreiung
mit einem befreiungsbescheid thome
verschwinden schmerz verschwindet es
gibt aber einen philosophen der für mich
sehr schön auf den punkt gebracht hat
worum es beim verzeihen möglicherweise
eben im kern geht er spricht davon dem
von dem waren im wirklichen einem
idealen verzeihen und da sagt er
das letzten endes das verzeihen
bedingungslos sein muss dass man eben
nicht sagt ich verzeihe um mein
seelenheil wiederzuerlangen ich verzeihe
um mich zu befreien oder oder den täter
zu befreien sondern dass es im grunde
etwas ist was auch so wie aus dem nichts
geschieht und ich denke dass das das
verzeihen sich genau in dieser spannung
bewegt dass es eben auf der einen seite
natürlich wenn es denn real werden soll
gebunden bleiben muss an bestimmte
bedingungen hat auch natürlich an die
erwartung eines bestimmten
wales aber das ist auf der anderen seite
eben immer dieses ideale auch in sich
trägt
wer nicht zur zeit hat dann irgendwie
diesen stachel im fleisch und lässt auch
das unrecht beim anderen oder pocht auf
wiedergutmachen darüber euch die später
noch mit ihnen sprechen aber sie haben
vorhin selber das stichwort rache auf
gemacht und ich habe mich dazwischen
wenn man wieder gefragt warum spricht
die frau flaßpöhler die überraschende
suchen
warum spielt das keine rolle ist rein
ich so gut ich meine vergeltung ist ein
anderes wort natürlich für rache und
vergeltung taucht auch oft auf also weil
eben dieser so zivilisiert rache denke
ich habe die königin der nacht aus der
zauberflöte hilft uns das feuer im hirn
ich glaube weil vielleicht spreche ich
darüber nicht so viel weil für mich ganz
persönlich die rache sehr ich sags mal
so die rachegefühle waren bei mir sehr
gedeckelt ich hatte nie wirklich offene
rachegefühle ich glaube ich habe auch
nie meine mutter wirklich so richtig
offen und intensiv gehasst das war
vielleicht auch ein problem dass ich das
nie so richtig konnte aber es war bei
mir immer eher eine form von eben
internalisiert im schmerz den ich mehr
oder weniger mit mir selber ausgemacht
habe und ich glaube das ist auch etwas
was vielleicht viele kennen also dass
das man gar nicht so sehr jetzt den
täter offenen hass sondern dass man viel
mehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt ist
aber es gibt über die rache natürlich
viel interessantes zu sagen und es ist
ja sogar auch so dass die rache auch
auch gut oder rachegefühle auch gut sein
können also ich nenne ein beispiel ich
habe auch in dem buch und firmenbuch bin
ich ins gefängnis gegangen und habe mit
lebenslänglich inhaftierten gesprochen
also unter anderem auch mördern und es
war ein bibelkreis und wir haben also
eine stunde lang über das verzeihen
nachgedacht und einer dieser dieser
herren die da also mit am tisch saßen
haben gesagt was glauben sie was hier
los wäre wenn nicht die inhaftierten die
rache die rache lust verspürten da
würden sich viele umbringen weil die
rache ist etwas was auch lebendig hält
dieses gefühl mir wurde da etwas angetan
und ich werde mich ich werde mich eines
tages dafür recht aggression gegen
aussen nicht gegen ihn
richtig und das ist auch dass das hat
natürlich was vitali ziehen das ja das
hält diese er hat das sehr schön
beschrieben das ist das hält die am
leben dieser rachegedanken und wenn sie
denen die hat gesagt wenn sie denen die
rache nehmen oder die rache lust nehmen
dann gehen die indi indi autoaggression
bei allem was vielleicht gut sein kann
verzeihen finde ich natürlich gibt es
klarerweise auch fälle bei denen man
denkt das sollte man nicht sein darf
noch nicht da sein auch um die eigene
würde zu behaupten
in diesem kontext ist mir ein film
angefallen er heißt philomena in der
hauptrolle judi dench ein britisches
filmdrama vom 2013
der film spielt in irland und jetzt ganz
kurz worum es geht philomena wie jetzt
auch eingesperrt in ein kloster sie wird
unheimlich schwanger kommt in dieses
kloster zu nennen wird
katholisch erzogen und muss zwangsarbeit
leisten das kind das sie gewährt der
antoni der wird ihr auch weggenommen
wird zwar akzeptiert sie sieht die nie
wieder
und erst sehr viel später entscheidet
sich diese phänomenale team von
journalisten sich auf die suche nach
diesem antoni zu machen und sie muss
herausfinden was an toni an aids
gestorben ist schon vor langer zeit und
das tatsächlich auch diese antoni seine
mutter gesucht hat aber die nonnen haben
verhindert dass die beiden sich wieder
finden um ziemlich am ende des films
kommt es zu einer sehr ergreifenden
szenen in dem es uns verzeihen geht und
diese szene möchte ich gerne mit ihm
zusammen anschauen
entschuldigen sie sich wie weiß damit
sagen sie dass es ihnen leid und hören
sie auch dinge zu verschleiern
gehen sie da raus und befreien sie die
gräber der verstorbenen mütter und babys
von unkraut und dreck ihr leid war die
buße für ihre sünden eine der mütter war
14 jahre alt martin es ist genug der
herr jesus christus wird mein richter
seien nicht leute ihresgleichen ich
glaube wenn jesus jetzt hier wäre würde
ja sie aus dem rollstuhl kippt man sie
würden nicht aufstehen wie die auf
martin aufhören nicht mitgebracht er mit
der hier einen aufstand veranstaltet
entschuldigen sie sich entweder hat der
aids und seitdem trotzdem nichts von
ihnen das ist mein schicksal nicht ich
muss sehen wie ich damit umgehe das ist
meine entscheidung
und was werden sie unternehmen nichts
oder nein
schwester hildegard
ich möchte dass sie wissen dass ich ihn
vergeben
einfach so nein nicht einfach so es ist
schwer es ist schwer für mich
ich will die menschen aber nicht hassen
ich will nicht so sein wie sie sie sich
ein
ich bin wütend
ja das muss anstrengend sein
schwester claire während sie wohl so
nett und zeigen mir das grab meines
sohnes
ja ich könnte ihn nicht vergeben
ich könnte ihnen nicht vergeben
ehrliches akteure dass meine position
auch und ich finde es fast so einen
stoßen dass die philomena hier sagt ich
vergebe ihm da zeigt sich viel allein
dieser szene also zum einen dass das
verzeihen etwas sehr persönliches ist
das wird ja sehr deutlich gesagt das ist
meine geschichte
ich habe das recht zu verzeihen nicht
sie das ist nicht ihre sache
das glaube ich ist sehr sehr war
gleichzeitig kann man aber auch sagen
stimmt das eigentlich
ich musste da denken an einen anderen
fall an den fall der eva muse score das
ist eine eine jüdin die am fünfzigsten
jahrestag der befreiung von auschwitz
sich hingestellt hat und gesagt hat ich
vergebe allen nazis also sie war selber
im kz auschwitz mit ihrer schwester
diesen zwilling
ich vergebe ein nazis und da haben sich
natürlich also ganz ganz viele damalige
mithäftlinge juden überlebende erzürnt
ja und haben gesagt sie haben dass sie
haben dazu kein recht weil sie selber
auch getroffen weil sie selber auch
betroffen waren da wird nur klar ist das
verzeihen tatsächlich eine ganz
individuelle entscheidung oder gibt es
möglicherweise doch eine moralische
frage die komplexer ist ja dass das sei
nur so an den rand gestellt dass da
könnte man jetzt sehr lange drüber
sprechen
das andere was mir da noch auffällt an
dieser szene ist das ja auch das
vergeben oder das verzeihen in dem
moment wo man es ausspricht
im grunde genommen ein verhältnis
umdreht ja also das heißt sie steht ja
sogar so ein bisschen erhoben erhaben
über dieser dieser kirchlichen
repräsentanten der eigentlich ist
vorbehalten ist sozusagen zu vergeben
das ist ja so das recht der der kirche
zu sagen ich vergebe dir deine sünden in
dem moment wo sie das ausspricht erhebt
sie sich über die über die schwestern
und sagt nach unten hin ich vergebe dir
das heißt also dieser spreche akt des
vergebens ist eine form von von
souveränität die auch und das sage ich
jetzt mal ich weiß dass provokant ist
auch eine form von arroganz in sich
trägt tragen kann
also sagt der ida der französische
philosoph spricht sogar von einer option
i tät ja dass das sozusagen diese diese
souveränität auch genossen werden kann
natürlich einen opfer täter verhältnisse
in gewisser weise umdreht man kriegt
dadurch handlungsmacht zurück was mich
eben zu der frage gebracht hat ist das
verzeihen dass vergeben überhaupt etwas
was ich aussprechen muss oder ist es
nicht vielmehr etwas was sich zeigt in
der konkreten auseinandersetzung mit dem
anderen immer in der art und weise wie
ich mein leben führe bei mir noch ganz
kurz mit dem punkt den sie wohin er denn
da sage ich dir echt interessant finde
das stimmt ja tatsächlich mama passiert
einem jahr diese situation dass einem
jemand sagt das mich unglaublich
verletzt aber ich vergebe dir verzeihen
und dann findet man dieses verzeihen
geradezu stoßen aber wenn man ich hab
dir überhaupt nichts getan und dies in
diesem ob es passt einem verziehen wird
einen eigentlich gleichzeitig auch
implizit gesagt du hast dich übrigens
schuldig genau richtig geld ganz genau
und das ist ja wie genau das passiert ja
hier auch das ja diese nun eigentlich
sagt ich habe absolut richtig gehandelt
und sie waren sich sündig verhalten und
ich habe sie dafür bestraft ich habe
überhaupt keine schuld und in dem
augenblick wo philomena sagt ich vergebe
dir sagt sie im grunde auch natürlich
hast du schuld und gleichzeitig ist es
ja auch so bei die sich sie gibt kann
die schule zurück das ist aber ich denke
mir auch sie schuldet ist doch auch sich
selber nicht zu vergeben man denkt doch
einfach das ist auch unwürdig es gibt
einfach situationen wo wir hart bleiben
müssen nicht sagen dürfen schwamm drüber
ich glaube dass man da etwas übersieht
nämlich dass das fast also taucht ganz
auf die formulierung auf man sieht man
sollte doch nicht man man darf doch
nicht und ich glaube da
da wird man dem verzeihen als als
ereignis und als hoch individuelle
handlung nicht so richtig gerecht weil
wir wissen nicht was in dieser in dieser
person vor sich geht vielleicht fühlt
sie sich tatsächlich so dass sie sagt
ich habe die kraft dazu es kann aber
auch sein und das ist ja auch etwas was
einem immer wieder auch begegnen wenn
man sich mit dem thema auseinandersetzt
es gibt auch so etwas wie ein
oberflächliches oder falsches verzeihen
also der französische philosoph paul
ricard weist darauf hin dass es
natürlich auch ein verzeihen gibt was
vor schnell passiert ich verzeihe dir
weil ich mich damit
mit dieser ganzen sache eigentlich nicht
auseinandersetzen muss und
weil ich lieber das ganze so ein
bisschen unter den teppich kehren will
und weil ich jetzt einfach mal aus
dieser opferrolle raus will
übrigens ist das auch etwas was die
famose score diese juden von der ich
wohin erzählt habe was auch für sie
denke ich ein stück weit zutrifft weil
es gibt einen film über sie wo sie auch
sagt ich will mich einfach nicht länger
als opfer fühlen ich will es nicht ich
werde es wie die anderen an diesem
moment der scham über das wir am anfang
gesprochen oder das ist dieses diesem
moment des unrechts was ihn einen rein
gekommen ist dass man das nicht aus sich
raus raus schieben stößt genau richtig
und trotzdem gibt es ja auch zum
beispiel den vladimir janocko levin
stehen sie auch erwähnen ein
französische philosophen der sagt mimi
wird da die shoah verzeihen die darf
auch nicht verjähren die muss erinnert
bleiben um nie wieder deutschland
betreten nie wieder ein deutsches wort
sprechen das hat er nie wieder tun weil
man passt einfach nicht auch ein stück
weit unvergessen machen darf richtig ja
diese haltung versteht man doch absolut
absolut also für janko wird übrigens
auch für hannah arendt ist dass das böse
die grenze des verzeihens die sagen ganz
klar in dem augenblick wo menschen
wissend sich eines verbrechens schuldig
machen und in diesem fall der shoah sich
eben auch gegen die menschlichkeit gegen
die menschheit schuldig machen
das ist und bleibt auf alle ewigkeit
unfassbar
zumal und da denke ich muss man eben
auch zustimmen die die wahren opfer sind
tot ja die sind gestorben in den
gaskammern wieso soll ich jetzt als
überleben da das recht haben zu vergeben
ich habe auch in meinem buch ich habe
mit zwei holocaust überlebenden
gesprochen und das war ganz interessant
weil weil deutlich wurde dass der mann
mit dem ich da sprach zwi steinitz heißt
der der sagt irgendwann ich bin gar kein
opfer ich habe mich nie als opfer
gefühlt ich habe überlebt ich bin kein
opfer
gerade deshalb alleine habe ich schon
nicht das recht zu verzeihen
das ist eine sehr findet das ist mir da
erst mal klar geworden ja die haben sich
nie als opfer gefühlt ja also gewiss
hier zumindest gewisse nicht und trotz
allem was ihm angetan wurde das fand ich
fand ich wirklich sehr interessant
ja ich verstehe die position von
jankovic ser sehr gut es gibt aber
natürlich 2
sage ich mal probe oder fragen die man
sich stellen muss nämlich zum einen die
shoah liegt sehr weit zurück gibt also
meine generation schon hat sich
natürlich nicht unmittelbar schuldig
gemacht an den juden
meine tochter die gerade acht jahre alt
ist ist noch mal ein stück weit davon
weg die frage die sich mir stellt und
sich auch in dem buch stelle
was passiert eigentlich mit dieser
historischen schuld trage ich die in mir
gibt es so etwas wie eine erbschuld eine
kollektive erbschuld und wenn ja was
heißt das eigentlich für die frage des
verzeihens das ist das ist sozusagen die
die eine frage die man sich denke ich
schon stellen muss also auch wenn man
sagt dass verjährten niemals gleich und
das andere ist das ja der jacques
derrida übrigens auch ein jüdischer
philosoph ja dieses sehr interessante
diese sehr interessante beobachtung
macht dass er sagt nur das unvereinbare
ruf nach verzeihung das was verzeihbar
ist das muss nicht verziehen werden wenn
ich ihr jetzt auf den fuß dreht und
nicht ein widerspruch in sich das
unfassbare muss tessiner in der
unterzeile heißt ja es kann nicht sein
aber er sagt ja nicht das muss verziehen
wenn es ruft harzer und da würde ich
sagen das ist etwas wahres ja weil weil
das was verzeihbar ist da ist dann auch
eben keine keine wirkliche schuld mehr
ja warum warum muss ich auf vergeltung
verzichten wenn ich etwas für verteiler
halte das ist dann wird das eine floskel
also in dem augenblick wo ich ihnen
jetzt irgendwie auf den fuß drehte in
der u-bahn und ich sage verzeigung da
ist ja nicht wirklich ne schuld
vorhanden sondern da wo sich die frage
des verzeihens doch stellt und ich sage
jetzt nicht dass man verzeihen muss oder
verzeihen sollte oder dass es überhaupt
verzeihbar ist aber da wo sich die frage
des verzeihens stellt da liegt eine sehr
sehr schwere schuld vor und dieser
dieser ausdruck des rufens das fand ich
schon sehr richtig ja dass da dann wird
da wird diese frage virulent und nur
kurz noch interessant ist ja dass die
philosophen die sich nach der shoa mit
dem verzeihen beschäftigt haben die
wichtigsten philosophen waren alles
jüdische philosophen immanuel vinas
sagte rita wladimir jankovic hannah
arendt das waren die wichtigsten und die
alle beschäftigen sich mit dieser frage
und natürlich wäre es vollkommen falsch
zu sagen wir muss
die shoah verzeihen aber ich will nur
sagen dass diese diese haltung von
mankiewicz fragen aufwerfen
vielleicht liegt in diesem moment des
nachdenkens über das verzeihen jetzt
spezifisch bezüglich der show ja auch
einfach das moment das man sich sagt
verzeihen könnte dann heißen zu
vergessen und gerade vergessen darf man
nicht aber es muss ja nicht zwangsläufig
heißen parteien muss nicht unbedingt
vergessen das ist übrigens eine position
die die famose score klar vertritt die
sagt ich verzeihe weil ich nicht länger
opfer sein will
aber ich vergesse nicht und sie hat
nämlich tatsächlich selber eine eine
gedenkstätte errichtet weil sie sagt wir
dürfen das nicht vergessen nie und
nimmer trotzdem verzeihe ich also sie
versucht beide momente zusammen zu
denken und das gilt ja auch für sie also
unschuldig weit saugen sie schon am ende
des buches ist sie wissen nicht so recht
ob sie ihrer mutter verziehen haben aber
irgendwie schon zumindest vorläufig aber
sie vergessen sicher nicht sonst hätten
sie dieses buch nicht geschrieben
genau also da muss man sowieso fragen
was das vergessen eigentlich bedeutet
also dass vergessen wenn man sagt
verzeihen setzt voraus dass ich vergesse
dann heißt das natürlich nicht dass ich
jetzt wirklich vergessen also eine art
amnesie habe ja und vergesse was mir da
passiert ist sondern vergessen heißt er
das dass das ereignis selber keinen
schmerz mehr auslöst sondern sich die
bedeutung die psychische bedeutung
dieses ereignisses verändert hat also da
da denke ich dann muss man auch diesen
diesem begriff des vergessens irgendwie
noch mal sehr deutlich klären was ich
auch versuche und das andere ist sie
sagten gerade ich bin mir nicht so
sicher ob ich meiner mutter verziehen
habe was ich sage ist der satz ich habe
verziehen ist nicht zutreffend weil wenn
das verzeihen tatsächlich eine verzicht
leistung ist ich verzichte auf
vergeltung dann dann hat der satz ich
habe verziehen und ungefähr dieselbe
gültigkeit wie wenn man sagt ich habe
mit dem rauchen aufgehört habe also das
heißt es kann schon sein dass ich jetzt
gerade mal aufgehört habe aber ob ich
das in drei jahren auch noch tue das
habe ich das ist sozusagen vollkommen
unklar
das heißt also für mich immer ich kann
eigentlich nur sagen ich verzeihe
und das ist etwas was ich eben in der
zeit zeigt
und was natürlich auch voraussetzt dass
das fordert dass sich die schuld nicht
wiederholt ja also ich denke da jetzt an
das beispiel einer frau die vergewaltigt
wurde
die ihrem täter vergibt ihm verzeiht und
in drei jahren vergewaltigt er sie
wieder
ob die frau dann immer noch sagt ich
verzeihe dir ist eher fraglich
das heißt es ist etwas was sich in der
zeit ereignet jetzt haben wir
angesprochen über dieses persönliche
verzeihen über den versuch mit diesem
moralischen schuldenschnitt irgendwie
klar zu kommen
man kann sich aber trotzdem auch fragen
welche institutionellen maßnahmen
braucht es gerade wenn auch die schule
die institutionell war von vielen
gemeinsam ausgeübt mit recht
durchgesetzt oder mit rechtslücken
erlaubnis zumindest und gerade bezüglich
des films lina stellt sich diese frage
ja und die schweizer 2014 ein
bundesgesetz erlassen
zur aufarbeitung zu rehabilitieren auch
der abend ist er aktiv versorgten
dazu gehört eben auch eine unabhängige
expertenkommission die das ganze jetzt
historisch auf arbeit das gehört dazu
auch ein runder tisch an dem man sich
darüber austauscht war es eine
wiedergutmachung bedeuten könnten
was genau hilft gibt es zeigen welche
ich weiß nicht empirischen untersuchung
was genau hilft es dem konkreten opfer
wenn sozusagen von behörden seiten her
solche maßnahmen ergriffen werden
also ich glaube es hilft insofern als
dass das leid anerkennung findet weil ja
ein teil der des problems auch ist dass
die opfer sich alleine fühlen in ihrem
leid dass sie kein gehör finden ja dass
das das immer noch von seiten der der
täter gesagt wird ich habe da haben wir
uns überhaupt oder in schweigen herrscht
sogar eher dass das ist glaube ich mit
eines der größten schwierigkeiten auch
mit mit so einer tat umzugehen dass man
eben keine anerkennung findet für das
was man da für das eigene leid dass das
nicht gesehen wird also insofern würde
ich sagen das leistet das schon
gleichzeitig muss man aber natürlich
auch hinterfragen ob es denn dann wieder
gut ist
so lässt sich wirklich eine schuld
aufwiegen durch eine entschuldigung
durch durch geld möglicherweise auch
also durch zahlungen
da war man auch in der
philosophiegeschichte sehr skeptisch
also ich denke da an friedrich nietzsche
der das so genannte äquivalenzprinzip
kritisiert hat ja dieses
äquivalenzprinzip das ist ein ganz altes
prinzip was im grunde besagt du hast
dich schuldig gemacht und jetzt musst du
dafür bezahlen und zwar zunächst mal die
schmerz ja also die folter zum beispiel
ist ein ganz klares bestrafungs mittel
und oder eben auch was ist dann viel
sublimiert da und er das was wir heute
kennen der gewissensbisse
man hat sich schuldig gemacht und das
beide buße tun in diese schulen also man
muss irgendeiner man muss ein
schmerzempfinden ja oder dann später man
muss zumindest schmerzensgeld zahlen
oder was auch immer also man muss in
irgendeiner form diese schuld wieder gut
machen und da stellt sich natürlich die
frage gibt es da überhaupt jemals eine
form von äquivalenz kann man schuld
überhaupt so bemessen also vielleicht
nicht und trotzdem verstehe ich das
natürlich viele opfer sagen wir wollen
auch geld sehen weil sie erstens
tatsächlich finanziell getrennt wurden
zum teil haben die eltern dieser kinder
oder dieser jugendlichen sich schwer
verschulden müssen weil die nämlich
bezahlen müssen was kommt in diesem film
auch vor weil die bezahlen mussten für
diese um erziehung ihrer vom weg
abgekommen kinder wie man sich das
erklärt hat und zum teil diese schulen
weiter vererbt wurden und zum teil diese
menschen einfach auch nicht mehr fähig
waren sicher einzufügen nach ein
arbeitsleben sie werden von sozialhilfe
abhängigen erleiden eigentlich nebst dem
seelischen leid noch eine finanzielle
wird also insofern ist das natürlich
völlig richtig dass ist da nur eine form
von von von zahlungen und von schuld
ausgleich im finanziellen gibt das will
ich überhaupt nicht hinterfragen
die frage ist nur ist es denn damit
jetzt gut und da würde ich sagen nein
also man kann diese schuld nicht in dem
sinne zurückzahlen man kann sich da auch
nicht freikaufen in dem sinne etwas was
mich auch unglaublich interessiert in
diesem zusammenhang ist dass es auf das
phänomen gibt der öffentlichen
entschuldigung sie haben ja vorhin
gesagt etwas was wichtig ist für die
opfer ist
leid und montiert und das kann man zum
beispiel zeigen indem man ein
entsprechendes gesetz zur aufarbeitung
aber eben auch in dem sich jemand
entschuldigt und das ist auch in diesem
fall passiert 1010 hat sich die damalige
bundesrätin widmer schlumpf hat sich im
namen des bundesrates entschuldigen und
für mich passiert in dieser figur
eigentlich etwas was sie vorhin im
zusammenhang mit philomena erwähnt haben
von der anderen seite her
also wenn ich mich entschuldigen blicke
ich eigentlich auf die wenn ich sage ich
verzeihe dir wirklich auf das opfer
herunter und gebt dem auch schuld wenn
ich mich entschuldige dann sage ich aber
auch ich nehme also du hast mir jetzt
sozusagen auch zu vergeben da sehr
schwer nicht sagen nähe kannst dich
jetzt aber nicht entschädigen
das ist der begriff der entschuldigung
ist natürlich selbst entlarven
also ich entschuldige mich das ist ja so
als könnte ich mir selber meine schuld
nehmen also ich entschuldige mich
das ist eigentlich eine völlig unsinnige
formulierung weil natürlich die
entschuldigung immer abhängig vom
anderen also die gibt es die gibt es nur
zwischen zwei personen oder ich meine
auch so ein satz wie ich verzeihe mir da
da sagt karin das ist ein virtueller akt
vor dem spiegel das ist das hat
überhaupt keine keine realität überhaupt
kein gewicht an die kurzwahl der politik
solche momente gibt es ja immer wieder
und sie erwähnen zb joachim gauck
wirklich in griechenland entschuldigt
hat und der damalige
präsident jetzt zählen sie die
geschichte im arbeite ich so plastisch
ja also die die wehrmacht hat 1943 in
einem kleinen griechischen dorf linke
des 83 menschen im zuge einer
vergeltungsaktion ermordet also eine
schreckliche schreckliche
kriegsverbrechen und der gau ist dort
hingereist also unser bundespräsident
ist dorthin gereist und hat also im
rahmen einer gedenkfeier um
entschuldigung um verzeihung gebeten für
diese verbrechen und hat dann im grunde
genommen so im zuge dieser dieser
feierlichkeit auch den den griechischen
präsidenten so umarmt also ihn
regelrecht vereinnahmt in dieser geste
auch und und der der griechische
präsident hat sich dann so mehr oder
weniger herausgefunden aus dieser
umarmung aus dieser vereinnahmung und da
zeigt sich natürlich etwas dass eben
gerade diese diese politischen formen
der entschuldigung immer auch etwas
irgendwie theatrales etwas sehr
instrumentales und auch etwas
zwanghaftes an sich haben weil man also
man kann auf der einen seite sagen es
ist wunderbar dass ein deutscher
bundespräsident endlich mal worte findet
und die schuld an erkennt und das auch
öffentlich sagt für auch sowas gauck
immer wieder mal sehr immer wieder macht
und gleichzeitig kann man aber sagen
steht es ihm sozusagen überhaupt zu um
verzeihung um vergebung um
entschuldigung zu bitten als präsident
als als jemand der jetzt auch gar nicht
selber konkret täter war geht ihm das
möglicherweise auch viel zu leicht über
die lippen ist es auch möglicherweise
nur ein versuch eine form von
politischer normalität
wiederherzustellen also da wird klar
dass man sich ganz schnell auf eine sehr
seltsame ebene begibt wenn man das
verzeihen instrumentalisiert im
politischen sinne ja also da zeigt sich
dass das verzeihen eigentlich etwas ist
was sich jenseits dieses instrument
allen ereignet jetzt wenn ihr noch
einmal an
vielleicht ein stück weit abstand nehmen
von dem ganzen und uns einfach mal
überlegen wie lange das gedauert hat mit
diesen versorgungen dann muss man auch
mal festhalten das dauert bis 19 81
ich war damals das aufgehört hat acht
jahre haut und ich habe meine eltern
gefragt musst du dir davon
ich habe andere leute gefragt im
gleichen alter wie man eltern und alle
sagen unisono wussten wir nicht
ist nicht zu uns durchgedrungen und da
frage ich mich manchmal frau voßkühler
was geschieht eigentlich gegenwärtig
alles wovon unsere kinder und später mal
fragen werden habt ihr davon nicht
gewusst
denken sie das wiederholt sich dauernd
also ich finde wir sind gerade jetzt in
einer historischen situation wo man sich
sehr gut vorstellen kann dass irgendwann
die eigenen kinder fragen und was hast
du eigentlich gemacht was das nun dass
bezüglich der flüchtlingskrise die wir
in deutschland wahrscheinlich nochmal
viel unmittelbarer mitkriegen als als
sie hier in der schweiz aber wir erleben
das hautnah was da passiert also in der
in der schule meiner tochter das 200
meter von uns zu hause entfernt sind 200
flüchtlinge untergebracht
da engagieren sich ganz ganz viele leute
ich auch punktuell aber sicherlich nicht
so viel wie ich könnte da frage ich mich
manchmal schon was was irgendwann unsere
kinder sagen werden ja was hast du denn
eigentlich da konkret gemacht in dieser
situation hast du da irgendwie eine
initiative gestartet hast du dich
irgendwie eines flüchtlings einer
familie angenommen
auch jetzt im politischen sinne ich
meine wir sind gerade glaube ich
wirklich in einer historisch extrem
schwierigen und heiklen position also
die frage wie viele flüchtlinge nehmen
wir auf gibt es eine obergrenze haben
wir die moralische pflicht menschen
aufzunehmen wenn ja wen also das sind
hoch philosophische hoch moralische
fragen die gerade virulent sind und wenn
man sich die politische lage anguckt
dann geht ja die gesamte tendenz in
richtung abschottung wir müssen
irgendwie uns abschotten und wir müssen
irgendwie sehen dass europa heile bleibt
und intakt bleibt und handlungsfähig
bleibt wie es ja immer so schön heißt
das ist auch immer wieder die rede davon
dass wir ja überfordert sind wo ich mich
auch immer frage ja was heißt eigentlich
genau über forderungen fängt
überforderung schon an wenn meine schuld
wenn mein kind mal keinen sport hat wo
beginnt das eigentlich also ich finde
gerade jetzt muss man sich das sehr sehr
ernsthaft fragen ja ich danke ihnen sehr
frau flaßpöhler auch für dieses offene
ende wo es natürlich noch viel zu
diskutieren gelbe dankeschön wortlos bin
und ich danke auch
den vielen lena zeigen wir ihnen heute
abend um fünf nach 8 auf sf1 gleich
anschließend um 20.14 sehen die die
sendung reporter über ursula biondi die
selber administrativ versorgt wurde und
seit vielen jahren für die aufarbeitung
dieses unrechts kämpft
weitere hinweise zum film und zum
rahmenprogramm gibt es auf unserer
website
ich begrüße sie nächste woche wieder
hier zu einem gespräch mit karin el
fekki eine frau die dermaßen erhellend
und charmant überrollen die wiederum sex
in der arabischen welt erzählen kann
dass ich sie nicht verpassen sollten
ich spreche mit der fähre über die
silvesternacht in köln und über
strategien gegen sexuelle gewalt
bis dann eine gute woche
[Musik]